Chinese medical officials say they are
investigating the scientist who claims
to have created the world's first
genetically edited babies Hong Jian Quay
says the twin sisters were born with the
immunity to HIV the virus that causes
AIDS now he claims he altered their DNA
in a lab using a gene editing technique
called CRISPR dr. Tara nurullah shows us
why other scientists find this very
alarming Tara good morning if the
medical and scientific community are
very upset about this they are outraged
you understand it well absolutely
absolutely I mean I think this was
really done in a totally unethical way
ethical way the controversial research
was roundly condemned because it was
shrouded in secrecy and broke with
international scientific norms but Hajin
Quay says his breakthrough can protect
children from a dangerous and deadly
disease and that he's on the right side
of history the technology to genetically
edit human embryos has been around for a
while but scientists were unwilling to
cross that ethical line until now I
believe family need this technology and
I'm willing to take the criticism but
they heard Jen Quay a Stanford and Rice
University trained physicist says he
used the technique CRISPR to help a
marry chinese couple conceived twins
immune to HIV when the girls were still
embryos he used chemical scissors to
turn off a gene that makes people
vulnerable to HIV infection the embryos
were then implanted into the mother and
Lulu and Nana were born earlier this
month no gene was changed except the one
to prevent the girls are safe healthy
babies China's National Health
Commission ordered an investigation into
his work which defied a global
scientific consensus banning the use of
genetic editing on human embryos hos
University in China where he was on
unpaid leave said it was deeply shocked
by his research which it believes
seriously violated academic ethics and
codes of conduct I think this was
irresponsible
Karen Moussa nuru an associate professor
of medicine at the University
versity of pennsylvania believes this
was an attempt to engineer genetically
modified human beings no question that
that is unethical I would actually add
immoral to that Muhsin aru reviewed some
of his scientific data and says he
believes the genetic edits on the
embryos were incomplete meaning the
girls may not be totally immune to HIV
mu sooner also says there's evidence
other genes were edited unintentionally
potentially increasing the twins risk
for cancer taking those embryos forward
through pregnancy to live children to me
is absolutely appalling and horrifying I
can't imagine why anyone with any sort
of compassion would actually do that
Howe will formally present his findings
Wednesday at a scientific conference in
Hong Kong Rice University said the work
described violates conduct guidelines of
the scientific community and launched an
ethics investigation into Michael Dean a
bioengineering professor who's part of
hos research team so are there rules to
stop other scientists from doing this
there's nothing and that's really what's
horrifying the United States and Europe
have rules that really say this cannot
be done this type of experimentation in
embryos but China and other nations
don't and this is really prompted an
outcry as you said from the scientific
community calling this genetic Russian
Roulette unconscionable immoral and
you're really changing not just the
genetic code of these children but the
genetic code of their children children
and their children so they passed along
it is passed along and what's what's so
crazy is that this was presented on
YouTube in a series of videos where he
says healthy babies were born we don't
know if they're healthy babies we don't
know if they will turn out to develop
cancer if they will have problems with
other infections like West Nile virus or
influenza or other mutations so this is
really how would parents of people in my
era
why would parents agree to do this we
don't really know what they consented to
the consent form said HIV vaccine trial
so it's unclear what was really
explained to them if they really
understood the full consequences of what
was being done that's amazing one person
making a decision to affect person
changing the genetic code of the human
race for generations or two generations
Tara thank you